there is a secret to the products that
have been built out of silicon valley
which is that many of the largest
products that have ever been built
whether these are social media apps or
whether these are marketplace companies
whether these are collaboration tools
like slack and zoom and dropbox and air
table and ocean and so on what network
effects tells you is for this style of
product these are products where the
more users that use them the more
valuable the products become
andrew chen welcome to the show
thank you for having me man we were just
talking how did you find the time to
write a 400 page book with all of the
other stuff that you do
uh well the the fun part about it was it
was just like having two jobs um at once
and this was also one where um having
having the covet uh you know break
actually um made it so that when you're
stuck at home it's like having your own
uh walden pond uh you know you're you're
just stuck in your office and you're
like what am i gonna do i'm just gonna
you know write this whole thing uh but
no actually um i i ended up um doing a
bunch of really funny things just to
force myself to write and so i not only
put everything in my calendar i actually
um uh
turned on all the i had a separate
computer with just the apps for writing
on it and i turned on all the like kid
protection safe things so i blocked you
know twitter and reddit and all my
favorite websites uh you know from the
thing and uh and then and then i just i
just tried to write as as much as i
could um so anyway it was it took three
years but but now now i'm here which is
great big lift man it's so funny now
that um our habits on particular
machines
mean that we need to create our own like
you say walled off gardens that are
these little oases of work and these
stupid games you've got a time box which
i use as well to lock your phone away i
know that you've got one of those um
yeah man how important obviously so your
your job advising companies investing is
an executive role like by definition
it's an advisory role but you do a lot
of writing so how important has having a
public-facing communication channel been
for someone whose main job is kind of a
bit more back of house
yeah well i think um one of one of the
big things that um that the people think
about as an investor if you break down
the skill set you basically can say
there is a sourcing part of the job
right that's getting that's that's
making sure that all the most
interesting startups come to you and
you're you're meeting them in the first
place there is a picking part of the job
where you try to make sure that uh
you're picking the right startups and
that is very very hard it's very random
especially because you're often
in in the case of uh you know clubhouse
for example i met the team when they
were two people they had 500 daily
active users when we led the investment
i was one of the first hundred or so um
users on the product and so it's it's so
early it's so random um so how can you
make sure that that you're picking the
best ones there's a third uh dimension
which is winning
um which is making sure that the the
startups that have a lot of options for
investors that they pick you over over
others and then there's operating and
making sure that you're actually helping
the companies after the investment and
so
the nice thing about writing a book is
it actually touches a lot of different
aspects of those four skills and so um
when you write a book it's obviously uh
you know number one um kind of an
advertisement of your of your of your
skills and your expertise out in the
world that's very um helpful and people
um know me uh uh partly from my blog and
for my social media already and so the
book is kind of an extension of that um
writing the book forces you to
refine your thinking uh down on on on a
piece of paper that you're trying to
describe to people and so that has
actually been really helpful for from a
picking standpoint because now i'm like
okay yeah what retention rates do i
think about how do i evaluate if company
actually is has momentum or not um and
then and then for winning um you know
the the it's it's by being an expert in
a space it's great and then operating um
it's so it's going to be very very
helpful once the book is out um in in
six days to be able to actually hand the
book to entrepreneurs and say you know
hey this is this is how i think about
things
and and uh you know and have a high
density way to convey a lot of uh
information is there a matthew principle
going on here with the best known
investors then surely the startups that
think that they've got the best
opportunity of succeeding want to be
attached to the investors and the
advisors that are the highest profile
because they think this person's going
to make me be more successful so if
you've got this very well read blog this
twitter this book that's going to be
hopefully successful
that means more people come to you
are you starting to see or has it
already happened that it's stratified
out into the habs and the have-nots a
little bit in the investing world
it's just changing so okay so there's a
great book actually that i'd love to
recommend which is um uh called valley
boy and it's uh by um uh tom perkins who
started kleiner perkins one of the one
of the oldest venture capital firms and
if you go back to that period of time he
was literally driving around um the
midwest knocking on the doors of
insurance companies trying to get them
to to to back you know venture capital
and so and so because of that that whole
early period of venture capital which
was in the 1960s 1970s was very much
about how do we even raise money from
pension funds and insurance companies
and things like that to even go invest
and so what that's tended to select for
in
many of the early years is even if the
initial vcs were
operators and folks who would really
build companies by the second or third
or fourth generation they tended to
actually get people that were more like
kind of finance backgrounds um you know
in all this and so we've gone through
this long evolution and the circle back
where now i think um you know social
media and twitter is just such a huge
part of of of being um
of being an investor because now capital
is plentiful
and so folks that are um amazing on
twitter like my friend turner novak who
all he does is post memes uh you know on
on twitter or you have uh you know ryan
hoover and you have a bunch of these
folks that just have amazing um uh you
know um uh social media followings are
able to raise money and are able to
deploy so i always joke that you know a
lot of what we've done over the last 10
years of of uh startups has been to give
anyone credible two or three million
dollars um you know to to to to pursue
their dream which i think is amazing
it's great for the world
but now what we're going to do is we're
going to run another experiment which is
to
give all the social media um uh you know
influencers and give anyone who's who's
all the ceos that have a lot of
influencers 5 or 10 million dollars to
invest in
people they think are smart and we're
gonna see if that creates even more
startups um and on one hand you could
say oh is that is that you know is this
a good use of money i mean but look i
mean
startups are are are really the core
source of innovation um in the economy
and um and and i i for one am excited to
let anyone pursue their dreams um on
this even if i think they're they're
they're ridiculous because sometimes
they turn into amazing rocket companies
and electric car companies and you know
things like that uh and and i certainly
invest in many things that are for kids
and teenagers that nobody understands
either so um so i i think it's a great
thing given the entire uh lifespan of
startups and investing are you happy
that you're here right now would you
have found it really cool to have been
driving around in the 70s or do you
think that in 30 or 40 or 50 years time
there's going to be something incredibly
interesting or is this a hockey stick
sort of inflection moment that's a
pretty cool time to be an investor
i think it's an awesome time to be an
investor but i i always loved i always
love the idea of being able to hit the
fast forward button uh
if i can i think if anything what we're
gonna what we're seeing is um a rapid
decentralization and removal of
gatekeepers in the startup industry
overall um and and you know going back
to that original example in in the 70s
or 80s it was a very very small group of
people who were investing it was one
street sandhill road right next to
stanford university and it was literally
um you know operators and former
professors investing in the top grad
students at stanford it was a very
narrow uh you know group that you're
talking about and through that narrow
group we got great companies like cisco
like oracle like uh like google like you
know many of these but i i think i think
what we're seeing now is just this
incredible decentralization obviously
driven driven a lot actually by the
pandemic driven a lot by you know the
prevalence of remote work uh driven by
uh web 3 and the decentralized community
that has formed around it
and so i think more and more we're going
to see we're going to think about
this idea of sand hill road as almost
being kind of and silicon valley is is
is you know no longer exists i mean all
the companies all the really interesting
companies for the last 10 years have
been formed in san francisco not silicon
valley anyway not next to stanford all
everything in the city all the airbnbs
all the ubers all the um all the slacks
and so on have all been san francisco so
i think a lot of this is is now i think
slowly translating into more of like a
state of mind um it's the silicon valley
state of mind as opposed to um thinking
about it as if it's it's uh
um it's it's this fixed thing so i'm i'm
i'm very excited about the trend and i
think that um we're gonna we're gonna
just continue and and i think that it's
it's the same thing that's happening in
entertainment it's the same thing as
happy entertainment where where if uh um
uh where where having blogging software
and social media means that um you to
put something out you don't need to talk
to a media corporation you don't have to
get a book deal it's the same thing
that's happening in music it's the same
thing that's happening in um in in in
many many industries throughout and so
it's it's a really exciting trend it's
kind of dumb that people were still
constrained geographically in the age of
the internet and it took a global
pandemic to liberate
a little bit it feels like it was
probably a little bit overdue
way overdue and i think a lot of the the
hubs that um that have formed especially
in
um in europe in the uk i was just in
london a couple months ago and
it could
there there could not have been a
stronger moment uh for for the startup
community there with the number of vcs
and investments that are happening there
there's a lot happening in latin america
right now
there's a lot happening in in asia
southeast asia for a long time and
obviously in china and i think what a
lot of it the reason why this a lot of
this existed was when i moved to the bay
area in uh 2007
if you wanted to learn about these kind
of really interesting esoteric
topics if you wanted to learn about okay
how do i build a product that takes
advantage of viral marketing features
how do i measure virality okay oh
there's this viral factor thing how do i
measure retention oh there were these
these things called cohort curves you
had to literally talk to the people like
you literally had to go talk to the
operators that were building the
companies and ask them um i i originally
met for example eric reese
who wrote the lean startup many years
ago and and that company was doing a lot
around retention curves and nobody
nobody had written it down nobody had
written down so you so i literally just
talked to eric and just asked them how
they were doing things and we just
talked to talk about it and how how he
was building the idea around lean
startup and i thought it was really
interesting but these days it's like
that's all being pushed out into the
world you know we have we have endless
um uh you know we have podcasts we have
uh we have social media we have um we
have books we have all these things and
i think um what that means is that's
enabling a much much broader set
of uh individuals from any country um
and and i i think i think it's fantastic
it's it's a really um amazing time for
for to be a founder
what do you think most people
don't understand about network effects
well
i i wanna one of the
case studies that i use in the book is
um is google plus versus facebook and i
use this story because it's such a
fascinating one and we see it all the
time which is a bigger company sees a
startup being successful and tries to
just add a bunch of features and tries
to
uh copy it clone it you know try trying
to make it try to make it happen and
we're seeing it actually right now with
uh with with twitter and spotify and and
uh clubhouse you know for example um you
know this year and we're also seeing it
with um
um i i predict that we will start to see
a lot of uh sort of cloning behavior
happening for larger companies who want
to spotify creating an equivalent of
spaces and clubhouse they're they they
have yeah they have they have built one
[ __ ]
it's fine i love those guys and they
they should take their shot uh it ever
ever and it's great uh but but i would
say is uh um what you see in a lot of
these is and i use google plus as an
example is that um when google saw that
facebook was so successful they also
started a social network um project uh
to take it over and the way they did it
was they quickly built a ton of features
they made a huge priority inside of the
executives
and in order to get growth what they did
was they just put the google plus link
on the google.com homepage okay you
could put any link on the google.com
homepage and it would have 100 million
users like immediately
right and that's exactly what happened
right if you go back and you read the
news reports what happened was google
plus had you know 20 million users and
then 50 million users and 100 million
users and it looked like it was gonna
work
and then within two years it was like
over they like shut it all down
right even though it was you know
successful and then and and i think the
reason is because um when you get into
into network effects and i think this
this is maybe a good time for us to
cover the definition a little bit
these are there there is a secret to the
products that have been built out of
silicon valley which is that
many of the largest products that have
ever been built um whether these are
social media apps or whether these are
marketplace companies whether these are
collaboration tools like slack and zoom
and dropbox and airtable and ocean and
so on all of these
pieces of software ultimately
connect
different people together for an
activity
right and so airbnb is connecting hosts
and guests for travel based activity
is covering uh listeners and content
creators um for for for for us uh social
media um type uh activity and so on and
what network effects tells you is it for
this style of product these are products
where the more users that use them the
more valuable the products become
right and the telephone is a good
example of that a telephone by itself is
useless and there's an amazing quote by
theodore vale who was chairman of the
american telephone and telegraph company
aka t
um that basically says look telephone's
worthless the only its value completely
depends on the number of connections
that the network allows you to to have
and i think that's true and so what that
means is on one hand um that means that
if you have a product that has a lot of
connections has a lot of users it's very
powerful it can grow on its own it can
tap into viral growth it can use its
network to acquire more customers it
will increase its retention engagement
over time it will become a better
business model over time because more
people will upgrade when their friends
are using the product but simultaneously
and i'll get back to google plus now
it also means that if you
use a product and none of your friends
are on it or they're only lightly
engaged
then the product is just not valuable
it's not interesting to you and that and
that is the cold start problem right
that is the cold start problem because a
product that is uh valuable more
valuable when more people use it the the
converse of that means that it is not
valuable when no one's using it and so
the funny thing about google plus um to
go to go back to this example is when
you're inside of a big company and thank
god people think this way when you're
when you are inside of a a big company
you want the biggest numbers as fast as
you can you want to do a big launch you
want to do the steve jobs turtleneck
thing um and get up on stage and
announce this amazing new thing that
you've done um but what it means is you
often just get a spray spray random
spray of users that aren't really
densely connected with each other versus
i think that this is the the the whole
theory around the cold start problem the
book
lays out why it is that so many of these
products often start in this small niche
and tend to grow from there
that's why so many products grow start
from high schools and colleges like
snapchat and facebook and tinder all
started in colleges and high schools and
grow from there that's why a lot of the
new bdb products we we see grow from
individual teams inside of a company
before growing and taking over the
company like a slack or a zoom or
dropbox you know that's how that's how
they grow
and and marketplaces like airbnb
start out in austin texas at south by
southwest a particular moment in time
and uber starts out in san francisco and
then grows city to city to city i think
it's it's really the the fundamental
explanation for why it is that these
these products tend to grow in this way
does this mean that some growth
marketers and companies are perhaps
not realizing the value of small
individual types of interactions when
they're first starting out because
they're potentially not going to scale
over a longer period of time that
everyone's looking at where can i apply
the maximum leverage when can i look at
scaling but i imagine that getting a
product from zero to
ten thousand users or zero to a hundred
thousand users is very different to
getting a product from one million to a
hundred million users
that's right that's right exactly and i
think you have to divide it into
these individual phases and
paul graham who is co-founder of y
combinator had an amazing essay many
years back called do things that don't
scale
and and and i want to read just a
sentence or two from this essay because
i i think it's it's so um fascinating
and he's he's espousing kind of the
merits of just doing these wildly
unscalable things that don't just don't
sound like they make sense and and and
this is the first one that he talks
about
the most common unscalable thing
founders have to do at the start is to
recruit users manually
nearly all startups have to
you can't wait for users to come to you
you have to go out and get them and he
goes on to talk about stripe and how
they literally would individually try to
recruit people in the y combinator uh
you know class in order to use use the
product and and i think it's it's uh uh
when you're at a larger company or when
you come from a mind of broad-based
marketing you think about reach you
think about breadth you think about
building an impact across
a huge a huge amount of uh of of
airspace
and the problem is that's just not how
startups
should
create
network effects based companies you have
to be very very manual you have to
start and build very stable what i call
atomic networks these are networks that
are stable on their own you have to know
how many
users you need to get an atomic network
going so so so specifically
um a product like zoom if one of the
guys i interviewed for the book is eric
wong who's ceo and and and co-founder of
zoom and i asked him how many users do
you need for zoom to be valuable for
people to use it over and over and over
again and i think we all know that it's
valuable with even two or three people
right um you you can you can have calls
and it's great you can have meetings
it's fantastic something like slack on
the other hand is better
when it is being used by five or ten
people on a team together
um that makes more sense but if you zoom
out something like airbnb or something
like uber i mean you you talk to the
early airbnb people they say you need at
least 300 listings
in a city before airbnb is useful for
that city for uber you want to be able
to hit a button and get a car in
under 15 minutes and what that means is
you probably need a couple dozen drivers
online at any given time in order for it
to work and so that concept of an atomic
network what is the smallest network
that you can build that's stable and can
grow on its own and people can use the
product successfully is a really
important concept because if you can
build one atomic network and you can
build a second atomic network and the
third atomic network well you can
probably build 10 or 20 or 30 or 50. now
that doesn't mean that you can build a
thousand that doesn't mean that you can
build a hundred thousand of these
networks because once you get to that
you start to need to not do things
manually and you need to start thinking
about scale
and that's when growth marketing becomes
really important that's when thinking
about referral programs that's when you
start hiring many many thousands of
people um to build these companies but
but here's the funny part chris which is
that for in a larger company what ends
up happening is it's almost like the
companies become so successful that they
forget how to solve the cold start
problem yeah in the first place this is
exactly what i had in my head
so when you've got someone like google
who decides we're going to launch a
social media platform the presumption is
we're basically too big to fail we've
got all of these network effects already
in place because we have access passive
access to
i don't know how much but an absolute
terrifying amount of traffic that you
can just put onto the google home page
but you forget
that these atomic networks need to be in
place that also it's not just about
adoption it's about use it's about
ensuring that use is congealed around
particular groups of people it's
pointless having a hundred million
people all disparate and not connected
as opposed to if you had one million
people split up into thousand person
friend groups
that's right that's right and and so
thank god these big companies think this
way otherwise my business of startups
and venture capital would not uh would
would not exist um and then just to add
to that um i think the other asymmetry
when you're a big company trying to
build a new product is that
ultimately
every one of these networks once they
get too big they start to face
really really severe problems that are
just hard to solve
one of the big problems
is
how do you deal with market saturation
you've been tripling quadrupling
quintupling for so many years that
eventually you just run out of people
you know if you have a product that's
being used by a billion users how do you
double or triple or quadruple that at
some point what's an example of that
well i mean obviously all the facebook
platforms are like this i mean facebook
has has something like uh two billion
daily active users and so you know what
do you what do you what do you do
how do you how do you grow that right
and you can grow engagement but it
becomes much harder to grow your total
user base population encouragement
that's what we need yeah
that's right a breeding program yes
that's probably what they need um and
which is why they're starting a dating
app actually um that's that's maybe the
the secret plan in there um and and so i
think when you when you when you look at
that um uh that becomes one issue
another issue is overcrowding every
single one of these products you know
when when when you um email's a great
example email is amazing when you're
just
at a smaller team and you're just
emailing a couple people it's great as
soon as you're
somewhere where um and many of your
listeners will have this have a personal
experience with this if you work at a
company with 10 000 people or 50 000
people your corporate email is like a
disaster
like there's just too much
um and and that's true for social media
and that's true for you know any one of
these and i think that's why um for for
many of these products what happens is
as they um build their networks to
become much much much larger they
actually start to hit the ceiling that
really limits their ability to to grow
um you know beyond that point and and i
think what it means is that these larger
companies that we think of as invincible
you know we often think of a product
like um like facebook to be invincible
inevitably what happens is actually you
feel like when you use the main facebook
app chris i don't know last time you you
you went on there it's mostly um uh you
know
dog pictures and birthday birthday
parties at this point it's it's almost
like there's actually just too many
people
you know on on in the facebook platform
and so you actually want to segment it
down so that you can just talk to your
friends right and and no one wants to
use the same social network as their dad
right and so
you get to this very interesting point
where these companies that we think of
as
invincible many times actually are very
weak at their core and that's what
provides the opportunity for startups to
go zoom in to one piece of functionality
in these companies and just pick it off
and just do that one part really really
well and to build their own atomic
networks and scale their own atomic
networks to just make that happen um and
so and and so i think that that's
another important conclusion um out of
the theories of the book
it's a weird situation to get into where
for almost all of human history we've
wanted more information so a scarcity of
information has been the limiting factor
for acquiring wisdom wealth health
happiness
partners whatever it is that you want
and within the last decade
that has flipped from it being scarcity
to being in abundance and now the main
skill that you need is no longer being
able to forage for information it's
being able to filter information
that's that blows my mind man
well i i
i was just gonna say i went to uh the
getty uh museum in in in la and one of
the things that they had that i loved
was um these you know the manuscripts
that the monks would uh copy directly
and that's how you manually would make
these books and these books if you go
and you you know look at look them up i
think that it's something crazy like
each book was a luxury item because it
was like fifty thousand dollars of
modern day in history so if you had like
a library that meant you were just like
loaded because you had like a hundred
bucks that was like oh man you're like
uh you're 70 lifetimes of monk work
that's gone into your library yeah
exactly
that's right that's right now yeah
exactly now now we're now we're inverted
now now it's like we have so much uh you
know to deal with but that's exactly
what creates the opportunity that's why
you see
social apps like if you told me that
like tick tock could build a social
platform
and all it was was just going to be
dance videos
and they were going to be able to go
from that to you know all these other
things i think a lot of people would say
well why doesn't why doesn't youtube
just own this
you know it's their videos right but it
turns out that actually these niches if
you can build the proper networks around
them if you invent a new media format it
becomes really really powerful that's a
really interesting point so
it's not necessarily about having the
widest access to potential audience or
the widest access to the market it's
about having a
particular type of person on the same
platform that creates a magnified
network effect so you you mentioned it
before that facebook now just feels like
the most boomery platform ever and it's
i don't i use it for work that's it it's
just to keep up with people and you
think
why has that happened well because of
how widely it's been adopted some of the
reasons that made it cool in the first
place have been selected out
and now you start to go forward into a
more selective sort of social media
something like twitter where you don't
have to be on facebook you're expected
to be friends with the people that you
are friends with i don't follow my mum
on or my dad on twitter
on twitter i'm friends with them on
facebook but i don't follow them on
twitter so you know i don't that's sorry
dad um
and the same thing kind of goes for each
social social media network in each
individual product but it's so
interesting to think about the fact that
someone may look at let's say someone
looks at tick tock right and they said
that's that's cringe what are these
people doing doing these dance videos
it's like it's not for you that platform
isn't for you and it doesn't need to be
for you so this presumption that
platforms should aim to grow
at any cost to just acquire users
doesn't really make sense it's acquire
the right users
as well as you can that's that's right
and i think um you know the funny thing
is maybe it's just the natural life
cycle of these things that they all
become boomery um over time and dude
when they start saying it becomes
millennially i'm going to feel i'm going
to want to throw up in my own mouth
though i'm still in the the beautiful
grace period where millennialy isn't too
bad but and boomers like a slight when
that pivots god i'm gonna hate myself
i'm gonna look back on this conversation
and go you self-righteous wanker what
were you doing
nice yeah as a as a fellow uh elder
millennial i i i feel you on this um
yeah i i think that the um one of the
concepts that that um that exists in all
of these networks is that there's often
a
hard side of the network and an easy
side of the network and what i mean by
that is
if you take a network like uber
we would pay 500
to get a driver to sign up on the
platform but we maybe would only pay 10
or 20 bucks to get a rider to download
the app and try it and the reason is
because the drivers just do more work
they're just more important you know
they actually do they actually do a lot
and and that is and this concept is true
no matter what product category you're
looking at within within these um
network products content creators on
youtube are just more valuable than an
individual viewer
that's why all these companies are
paying
millions of dollars to content creators
and and that's that's all happening
right now um and because the the content
creators are the hard side of the
network um funny enough if you talk to
the tinder folks online dating the
attractive members of the of of of an
online dating platform they're the hard
side of the network they're really hard
to get they're really hard to retain
everybody wants them and so because of
that i think to to go back to the the
point that you're making chris
when you build a new product you need to
have some new innovation that makes the
hard side of the network
even more it needs to be really
compelling for them
and and what that means is if you're
building instagram you need to make it
so that the photo filters make the
content creators on there make their
photos look amazing um tinder i actually
have an amazing story um in the book
about about tinder which is i sat down
with sean radd who was um uh early
co-founder and he was the ceo of the
company for many years and uh shout out
to
sean um who also by the way had a major
uh court uh uh win today over his it's
very contested early um uh history of
the company which we can which we can
talk about briefly but um but he talked
about starting tinder in the very very
early days that
before tinder it used to be it was more
like a like classified listing this is
like what match.com was was set up as so
basically you'd have bob bob would put
his uh profile up on on match.com and
anyone could message bob
and the problem is let's say that bob is
just like a very attractive person very
well educated very successful
the experience for him actually sucks
because
uh the way that sean described it to me
he said look you go to work all day and
you answer email and the last thing you
want to do is um you know
open up your your your dating app and
it's just full of messages for you to go
and and
exactly that's right and at least you
know when you're at a bar or something
you can be like oh yeah these two people
are talking to this attractive person
i'm just gonna like talk to their friend
over on the side or something like in
the internet there was no in early
online dating there was no such thing
and people's inboxes would just be
flooded and so what tinder did that was
i think very very subtle it's not
something that is very well understood i
think is that by creating a right swipe
and a left swipe it allowed the most
attractive members of the network to
control the number of matches that they
were getting at any given time so they
were never overwhelmed and then by the
way also they made these decisions like
connecting your facebook and doing all
these other things to make the
experience for the attractive uh
desirable part of the network
more effective
and so that's all to say that i think
whenever you're building a new platform
for any of these where where it's a new
network
you need to have some kind of an
innovation like that otherwise what ends
up happening is
they would just rather use the other
thing the old thing right because if you
build a youtube and then you build
something that looks just like youtube
then it's like well youtube has all the
audience it has all the other creators
on there i'm just gonna go use that you
have to do something different enough
and i think this is one of the reasons
why i was so excited about investing in
clubhouse is that for folks like
you that have been able to build an
audience primarily using audio
as you know creating really high quality
content in audio is just different than
creating high quality video content
which is different than writing high
quality content and there's got to be a
place for people who are really
successful at audio um to to to to to
build an audience and so um so so i i
always think about that and and trying
to reset the order of of of things let
me let me stress test the uh the
clubhouse idea a little bit then what is
it that is helping the hard side of the
problem in clubhouse because presumably
there are low value conversations where
16 people just shout at each other and
there are high value conversations where
you accidentally get elon musk naval and
eric weinstein talking about the kanye
west's new album and there's you know
that that's people share it and
pirate it onto youtube like some old
school sort of like radio station how do
you on clubhouse incentivize the high
quality conversations yeah well i think
that um
uh
eugene way has an amazing essay and he
was um uh eugene way is an unbelievable
writer such an amazing writer yes and
this is his like kind of bread and
butter kind of area
and he has this concept that i love
which is called he calls it old money
okay which is
if you are a video creator
one of the reasons
even if you produce high quality content
that you may not be that excited about
getting on youtube now is that there's
too much old money
on on youtube people with millions and
millions of followers and how are you
going to compete if you're going to do
something from scratch and so in many
ways you're incentivized to actually
find a new platform a new network to
join
that
is just getting started
and if you're just getting started maybe
you have a better chance to get to
millions of subscribers so every new
network uh has this inherent attraction
to it that if it works you can reset the
order you can reset the hierarchy of
success and you can climb to the top
more easily creators have the
opportunity for first mover advantage as
well correct correct exactly exactly and
so i think what's happening is in the
podcast world which which chris you you
know so much about one of the reasons
i've been reluctant to actually start a
podcast has been i'm just like oh man
there's like so many podcasts out there
it's so hard to build an audience who
the [ __ ] am i up against tim ferriss
yeah exactly yeah yeah exactly right and
then you have like so and then and the
tools are so you know clunky uh and the
whole thing is just annoying and um and
what should i be doing instead and so i
think the one of the most interesting
things on clubhouse is that most of the
content creators on clubhouse most of
the people that start rooms most of the
people that um are are
creating recurring shows are not
podcasters
for the most part they are brand new
content creators that are not interested
in spinning up the whole stack to build
a podcast um they have no interest in um
uh you know trying to build a podcast
audience from xero against all the other
people and instead they're joining a new
hierarchy
um where they can they can just build a
new show and um and if clubhouse makes
the tools very easy if clubhouse is able
to continue growing um their audience as
they have then they can they can build a
new network and go from there it seems
to me like the trend is going from more
sophisticated to easier and uh more
frictionless so if you were to take
youtube and compare that with tick-tock
so tick-tock has in-built editing it's
got music there ready to go you can
everybody expects you to do with your
iphone in fact if you do it with
something that's more sophisticated than
an iphone you almost look a little bit
like you're trying too hard
um you compare clubhouse with podcasts
you've got this disgusting rss feed back
end thing with how it distributes it's a
it's archaic and insane and medieval and
primitive and then you've got press a
button on your phone and it streams live
to the entire world and people can tune
in and watch it do you see
that trend can't continue forever or
else you end up oversimplifying your
product out of existence and you just
end up with nothing uh
where do you see in terms of trends that
moving next yeah i i think i think just
to zoom out kind of historically right
you have to ask yourself why did this
focus on quality and curation where does
it come from in the first place and and
um and this is true you know we were
talking about books so this is true for
radio stations this is true for starting
up a tv show
right these are all used these things
were all very very hard and the reason
is because um in the pre-digital world
it was all about
finite self shelf space it was all about
having finite numbers of channels finite
number of time slots and so if you are
going to have a retail store that has a
limited amount of square footage and a
limited amount of shelf space every
single book should be the best book and
so what that does is that affects
everything down the chain right it means
that then the publisher wants to select
for only the most credentialed people
they want to select for only the the the
topics that they think are going to sell
the best and then as an author you end
up going into the same thing as well and
again you can you can you can
make make similar analogies for all the
other media types
and i think the the most amazing thing
about the internet is there's no shelf
space right you can just do whatever you
want and because you could do whatever
you want that means that the very first
thing in my opinion that gets filled is
all the casual content that is has never
had a place uh to to to exist in the
world that vacuum needs to be filled
right away and so i think that that ease
of use um uh as you say everything is
like you you publish a uh content you
know you publish text to the internet
using you hit a button publish text you
hit a button you publish video you hit a
button you you publish um audio and off
you go and and that's fantastic and i
hope that continues
um on the flip side though i also hope
that uh the internet and this in this
ever burgeoning market also provides a
um ability for the top end highest
quality content to also be successful
and i think we're seeing it already
we're seeing it because we're in the
golden age of uh you know dramatic
streaming uh you know television right
now and the fact that netflix has
infinite shelf space
they can just recommend different things
to different people means that they can
create you know these these massive
budgets to go fund television the
television shows that we've all wanted
to watch and uh and make a lot more
sense there than than streaming
similarly i'm a board member of sub
stack
where where you know they're doing the
same you know they have um a a program
called pro where they've been able to
get um some of the most amazing authors
and writers from from all over the place
to join substack
and this new business model of having
customers actually pay directly
into newsletters to directly support
writers has meant that writers who are
making you know writers are horribly
underpaid um in in in in the world and
um you know you get some of the best
writers you can pull them out we have
writers on sub stack that are making 5
million plus per year now i mean just
amazing um and and the reason for that
is because the whole market for that is
is just wildly inefficient and so i also
hope that um
all of this internet stuff also makes
the highest end content long-form
content serious content also grow as
much as all the short form silly stuff
uh that we see all all the cat memes and
all the uh
you know all the dance videos that are
out there yeah the two biggest
success stories i'm aware substance an
absolute monster but the two that have
been closest to my heart or that i've
watched the most closely was uh matthew
iglesias so co-founder of vice um you
know you think vices that's pretty big
time had its own tv channel huge youtube
huge website blogging writing etc and he
decides to leave to go and do his sub
stack and the other one was scott
alexander
moving from slate star codex to astral
codex 10 and that is
that that blew my mind um you know he
mentioned
scott's quite open door and he breaks
the fourth wall with a lot of this stuff
and he was talking about just how
amazing the team had been at sub stack
the fact that they'd helped him to port
over some disgusting amount of blog
posts like 10 000 articles or something
that was all going to be ported over
and he's now liberated to do his
psychiatry stuff as he wants in a new
location and that was all as a middle
finger to the new york times it's like
okay you're gonna you're gonna dock
somebody well the internet's gonna
brazilian jiu-jitsu that around and
you're gonna end up being the genesis of
this person's new life
that's right that's right exactly and i
think that that's exactly the point
about um uh having infinite shelf space
is that it means that any as long as
there's market demand um in in in in
these in these networks that are being
formed um all of a sudden you're going
to see um uh the hard side of the
network emerge um and and start to
supply whether it's content or it's
video or it's you know in in the case of
uh you know uh b2b um you know products
it's it's it's uh uh you know meetings
and conferences and all of that as well
um and so i think i think that this is
one of the one of the really important
trends that's happening in in the market
which is that um rather than thinking
about big monolithic networks that are
everywhere everything's open
everything's public increasingly a lot
of this is going towards these private
communities private networks web 3 is
obviously a very interesting you know
trend as well because what it's going to
do is it's going to allow these
communities to actually support
themselves and to monetize
you look at these projects like friend
with friends with benefits you look at
these
nfts like uh you know board apes and so
on
it's very much the idea of network
effects baked into uh crypto and web3
all together in one and i think we're
going to see a lot of new um business
models that are gonna um you know emerge
here and and it's gonna be really
interesting are you familiar with shiny
object social club
no i'm not tell me about shiny object
social club so my buddy is one of the
main guys behind it i've got a couple of
friends tom is a big part of it and um
they have created it's a discord server
and now a a bigger bigger community
connor my designer has been a big a big
part of pushing it as well all around
the nft space um but they've like
reversed backwards integrated themselves
with created they've forwards vertically
integrated themselves with uh the people
that actually want to buy they've
horizontally integrated themselves into
designers into people that supply into
people that understand coding into
people that have got different nft
projects and different
and it's just it's cool man you've got
um a
network effect project
that has had a community of people
create a network around it
that is a social club
it's the most meta thing ever but it's
sick
yeah it's here was a question i had for
you so we're talking about web3 and the
internet becoming increasingly
decentralized
is that going to change the nature of
network effects moving forward
yeah it's it's it's uh i i struggled so
much in writing the book
um on how much crypto how much web3 to
put in um because as you know it's
changing every week so i'm like oh man
if i write something uh and i put it in
there it's gonna be outdated in in in a
month and so you know what what am i
gonna do so i have a smattering of
things in there about uh about bitcoin
and ethereum
but i kind of kept it high level so
we'll have to wait for the the revised
second edition for me to add all the web
three um examples uh you know into all
this but but but i think i think that's
right i think i think it is it is what
maybe the most interesting um
aspect of um writing this book about
network of acts and seeing web 3 kind of
intersect at the same time because
to to to to to go to the example of just
bitcoin at the most you know basic
people value bitcoin because other
people value bitcoin
right and it's circular in that way and
in the same way if you were to start a
uh a different type of uh coin an
altcoin and no one was interested in it
even if you forked the bitcoin code and
you're running all the same code and
everything
you could have all the software exactly
the same but if you don't have the
network uh then it doesn't work and so
so at its core web3 has this cold start
problem in all these different um uh you
know uh uh ways and nfts in the same
thing and um uh crypto gaming is the
same thing if no one's playing axe
infinity it wouldn't be as valuable as
what it is and so so i think what we're
starting to see is first that all of
these theories um i think are going to
apply to web3
number one and i think number two i
think what's going to what's going to be
very interesting is we're just going to
see new creative ways that weren't
possible
in um in in the web 2 era i'll give an
example in for uber um one of the
programs that i ran at uber was the give
ten dollars get ten dollars referral
program at uber and this was an amazing
program we spent 300 million dollars a
year on this program when i was there um
and this was a period where we were
adding three percent of the world's
population to uber um as as the app and
it was just growing it was just it was
just hockey sticking
um but in the end we it we would not be
able to give
shares of uber to
the drivers or the riders you know
that's very hard right there you have
the sec you have all these things you
have all these regulatory issues um and
and so on um and and so it was all about
just giving people credit inside of the
rideshare system
what's amazing about web3 is that
it's it's really unlocking the ability
for the network participants to own a
piece of the upside
right a lot of web 2 is about maybe you
can get a revenue share maybe you can
get kind of like you know some discounts
um it's very cash based but there's no
ownership and so i think by having
ownership well what happens well then
kind of like a super referral program
you have like an amazing referral
program because it means that um
your users actually own a piece of the
network and they are heavily
incentivized to promote it's ethical
multi-level marketing on steroids
that's right that's right yeah exactly
that's right and and i think that we are
just in the very very earliest stages
we're going to see we're going to see
very complicated you know referral kind
of contracts models if you refer one
person this is what you get if you have
five people this is what you get um if
you're one of the first hundred people
versus the first thousand people you're
gonna have you're you're gonna have
various kinds of you know and i think
we're going to do a wild amount of
experimentation um and iteration on
making this all work and so i'm very
excited from like a growth marketing um
kind of user acquisition lens that we're
going to have to try all of this all
this stuff out
talking about metrics that companies
follow what do you think is some of the
most useless metrics that people have
focused on
oh yeah well i mean the whole lens of um
of of this theory is that the top level
numbers are the most meaningless
your total number of users you know your
total amount of revenue you know those
are those are what um what uh uh are
often referred to as these vanity
metrics because they make you feel good
they're the biggest numbers in the whole
business but in the end the question is
on a given like i'm a lot more
interested for sub stack
um
what the top writers are making
and are they happy and what's the churn
rate on the subscribers on an individual
basis i'm a lot more interested in that
than the overall revenue of the business
for clubhouse i'm a lot more interested
in
how many
recurring shows are they seeing how many
content creators are coming back
and creating show after show after show
and are they getting the audiences that
they want
that's a lot more interesting than the
total number of daily active users
and so i think the more operational you
are the more you're focused on that
authenticity the more you need to
dig in
um from from the user's perspective and
figure out what it is that that they're
into as opposed to the the top level
numbers i've just realized
the original way that clubhouse launched
with that
text only invite mechanism
that's a structural way of creating
atomic networks
that's right that's right yeah exactly
yeah and and and uh and maybe i'll talk
a little bit about invite mechanics for
it for a little bit um
so what ends up happening that's so
interesting with invites as opposed to
buying a user off of facebook or google
right i i hate it when startups pay
google or facebook i if i can avoid it i
i try to avoid it um and the reason for
that the reason why inviting is so
powerful is because
it means that every user that's joining
probably already definitely knows at
least one person that's already in the
network
definitely knows that that's just you
know fact but very likely knows multiple
people on the network and so what ends
up happening is um one of the case
studies i cover i i interviewed reid
hoffman um who was uh co-founder and and
originally ceo of linkedin and he talked
about how in the very very earliest days
what they found was there's a structure
in the professional market
which is that it's very very hard to get
bill gates to sign up for a professional
network product because everyone wants
an intro to bill gates he doesn't need
to talk to more people so he just he's
fine
um but
uh there are tons and tons of people
that are kind of still operating they're
still in the mid-level they're still
very open-minded they still want to
connect with a lot of people
and they're the entrepreneurs and the
founders and operators and so what
linkedin did in the earliest years was
they basically said um okay we're gonna
launch and we're gonna give everyone in
the company a ton of invites and we're
just gonna invite all of our friends and
all the people in the tech community
and what they found was
that very quickly
started to grow rapidly just on its own
and they eventually made it so that once
they got enough users they could
actually remove the invite constraint
because
just based on word of mouth
on average most users would join and
already know a couple people on the
platform but there's an exclusivity
element here as well which adds uh
prestige to being invited
that's right that's right yeah and
obviously you know linkedin is is much
more diffused now it's much more you
know it doesn't have that but like in
the earliest years i think that's right
i think i think all of these apps um one
of the things about invite only is
there's a lot of reasons to do invite
only one is i think the most important
and understated reason is exactly the
one that you put your finger on chris
which is making sure that people already
have connections the second is honestly
for a lot of these products they just
don't want to scale their infrastructure
that fast if you're growing you know at
one point clubhouse is growing 50 a week
you know it's like very hard to keep
your servers just up and running when
you're when you're when you're doubling
more than doubling um every uh every
every month you know that's very very
hard and then and then the third is you
definitely do get a lot of buzz just
from people thinking about you know
feeling left out now the funny thing is
that's not enough to sustain your
product
because if you get a lot of people
coming in and they're all there for the
buzz and it turns out that their friends
aren't in the product and it's not
working then it's just not gonna work
because these days how many invites do
we get into random apps it's just not
special anymore and so i think you still
need um you know you still need at its
core you still need uh you know the the
engagement and the product to be amazing
in order for it to be useful are you
familiar with raya
yes the celebrity dating app yes i i've
heard of it as uh um uh instagram models
dating um uh tech uh millionaires is
that is that accurate i'm not on it so
no neither am i but uh my buddy my buddy
who's a very famous comedian told me
about it uh two two netflix specials
very very well known and
he said with a lot of aplomb that he
wasn't accepted onto it and his his
invites still pending but with that when
you sign up you it connects to your
phone book and you go through and you
see all of your
phone contacts that are already users on
rhea
and then you select the ones that you
think will attest to you being a worthy
member and they receive a notification
inside of the app saying do you know
this person
that so they're looking for a uh
almost like a referral scheme uh for
quality
uh to make sure that people are of the
of the correct caliber you had um you
had some cool stories about how tinder
started as well
yeah that's right well and and i just
want to add on to what you just said
which is one of the fascinating things
about viral growth in in a case like
that most people think of viral growth
as you know you put out a really cool
video and everyone shares it and it's
like goes viral that's
that that's not what i mean um
what is really fascinating is there is a
science behind viral growth which is if
if you can get a thousand users who use
your app
to then invite
another thousand users
well those users are gonna invite
another thousand users and so on and so
on and so forth and it'll just continue
to grow
now if a thousand of your users only
invite
500 then that group will invite 250
right because it's about half and then
the 250 will invite one 125 and
eventually it'll kind of like die down
and it turns out that that ratio you can
measure as a viral factor
and you can arnold it's the unknown
yes well that's right yeah well now
we're all uh amateur epidemiologists and
so we actually know all these terms yeah
or not exactly and and so what ends up
happening is if you can calculate that
um it means that then you can come up
with clever ideas on how it is that you
should um you know increase that and i
think this whole references thing it
sounds like a very clever way for them
to
disguise an invite strategy
alongside a um uh you know uh something
that that that is aligned with their
brand um and and to bring it together um
yeah and so uh and then maybe i'll maybe
i'll cover tinder because it's such a
it's such a fascinating um early story
and on how they solved the cold start
problem um as as our as our final topic
um but the um so so tinder originally
was started um
sean
justin mateen uh and and and uh john
bedin and john bedin was the original
ios engineer on it he actually kept a a
bunch of cards playing cards on his desk
and you kind of play with the cards and
when they built tinder for the first
time originally if you look at the
original screenshots there was actually
a check mark and an x
in order to pass and accept there was no
there was no swiping and then john
actually added the swiping because um he
just thought it was fun and so he just
went off and and and did it and now it's
this iconic you know thing and so the
funny thing is when they originally
announced that they just tried to get
all their friends onto the platform they
would just text their friends and be
like hey i'm starting a new dating app i
think you should be on it
and the funny thing is if you think
about it that way that's kind of like an
insult that's like you seem like you're
lonely
i think you should probably be on this
dating app you know it's not the best
sell it's not the best sell and so what
they realized was they were like okay
how do we get how do we get we all we
need is we need a couple hundred really
desirable people on the app at the same
time and if there's awesome people on
the app people will stick
and so they ended up actually um
coming up with this amazing idea which
is they were going to sponsor and throw
a party for one of the really popular
girls on campus it was a birthday party
but and it was going to be amazing they
were going to like bust people from
campus and then they were going to have
like rent out this huge house and but
they were going to have bouncers in the
front it was going to be very exclusive
and you have you have to have installed
the tinder app
um and uh and and you'd have to have um
set up your profile in order for it to
work so they got 500 people to this
party
and they had an amazing party and the
next day
people open up the app and they're like
wow here's all these people that i
wanted to talk to that i didn't talk to
yesterday
and using those that that one party at
usc they were able to prove that they
could take over an entire campus
and once they knew they could take over
an entire campus then they would try
they would be able to do this on the
second campus and a third campus and
that became the core of
the the tinder strategy so they were
finding
networks the cool person or the cute
girl who had the big birthday party
coming up that's right run it make sure
everyone had tinder there's an atomic
network for this campus this campus this
campus
and once you get enough of them together
then they start to join you get usc and
you get ucla then you get la
right and then if you can get la you get
new york and you get san francisco right
and it kind of um you know spread spread
from there
but chris this is this is so wonderful
to be able to uh talk to you about uh
about the new book and i really
appreciate um being being on the podcast
i'm a huge fan and so it's great to
finally be able to talk my pleasure man
why should people go if they want to
check out more of your work
yeah so um the the book uh all the
pre-order links are on
coldstart.com um and then my main blog
where i've been writing for over 10
years and i've been publishing um i'm up
to almost a thousand essays is
andrewchen.com
awesome thanks chris andrew thank you
man
all right thank you very much what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace